thanks to Wes Anderson's onset
atmosphere the cast of asteroid City
formed lifelong friendships throughout
the filming process but that was nothing
compared to Maya Hawk's spontaneous
dance choreography Jeff goldblum's blind
walk-in stilts and the chaotic UFO scene
that very well could have sparked up a
few losses
Wes Anderson has a zany childlike
excitement when it comes to Stepping
onto his set hope Davis has been friends
with him for many many years now but
didn't realize just how much fun he was
to work with even after with all these
movies on his belt he still relishes the
shooting day every minute of it when Wes
was working on Rushmore back in the day
hope was staying in the same hotel as
him working on a different film so she
would visit him in his hotel room just
to hang out now because this was like
well before Spotify and even
pre-internet era finding music for your
film was a totally different vibe he had
stacks of records that he was sorting
through to find the tracks for Rushmore
this was her first impression of him
when it came to making films so she knew
he was passionate but she didn't know
just how much fun he would be to be
directed by it's a rare thing to be in
the hands of someone that no matter what
they say to you you're gonna think yeah
yeah I'll do that all the chemistry
between actors that you see on set isn't
actually just acting well I mean it is
but a big part of that is by Design he
designs an atmosphere where we're living
together and we're eating together so we
get to know each other this is a big
part of Wes Anderson's set Vibe he
doesn't want the actors to have to try
too hard we become friends and then we
become a family and then everything is
just organic that's what everyone says
makes him such a great director he
understands actors and how to guide them
to their performance in an elegant way
apparently Maya Hawk and Rupert Friend
were not hired for their dancing skills
oh there was no we're hiring you to do
because of this it was um they would
have hired other people when they first
read the script the only direction that
was written when it came to the musical
number was they danced there wasn't even
a rehearsal or a choreographer it was
probably the most spontaneous musical
number you'll ever see in any film it's
one of those moments of spontaneity and
exuberance that I think make this film
such a joy to watch Adrian Brody has
worked with Wes Anderson five times and
Jeffrey Wright has worked with him twice
now supposedly he did a nude of Mitch
Campbell too and
there are several reasons why they keep
coming back but of course one in
particular is how much Wes pushes them
both as artists it's a privilege and a
pleasure to come to set and this one's
no exception there are dozens of other
reused asteroid City actors in the West
Anderson World probably not unless maybe
it is to name a few Scarlett Johansson
Jeff Goldblum told us smitten and Neeson
Schwartzman they all keep coming back
something that might surprise people
about being on the set of a Wes Anderson
film is that he doesn't prefer to have a
lot of people around when shooting
scenes especially considering just how
large the cast of asteroid city is how
can one even achieve something like that
he's just right there it's the feeling
of intimacy in a movie that looks you
know it's got all these people one of
the major pluses for that type of
setting is that West doesn't have to
raise his voice when directing the
actors he's just right there nobody was
ever really on set that didn't have to
be there for that specific scene
something the actors really appreciated
about being on set was just how open to
interpretation everything was whether it
be how the dialogue was delivered the
interpretation of said dialogue or
really anything at all the actors wanted
to add to the character Wes Anderson was
up for it and honestly excited about it
that's what he loves about being there
when you describe his onset
vivaciousness that is the thing now
obviously if West does have notes about
dialogue or what's happening it's
usually specific it might be sometimes
you know he's like take a little air out
of it but leaves it up to the actor to
fill in everything else all of his
projects are very much a collaborative
process
something Maya Hawk learned on the set
of this movie was the power of tailoring
never before in her entire career had
she ever had something so well tailored
to her than the dress that June wears
the way that I could move in it and and
it changed shape and it could get sweaty
she said she felt so strong in that
dress and after wearing it on set it
made her want to go home and get every
piece of clothing she owned tailored to
fit her now something you might not know
is that Rupert Friend actually learned
how to lasso for the movie they didn't
really use it a lot for the movie but he
spent many many hours learning and
perfecting the craft I spent a long time
with a rope and a post and a really
great guy once he got the hang of just
the lasso part he got on the horse and
started trying to capture the post with
the Rope while riding on hours back and
like even though it didn't really get
used for the movie it was one of his
favorite experiences when it came to
filming we all know Scarlett Johansson
is a force to be reckoned with on screen
but Jason Schwartzman found himself
describing her as some sort of magician
when he would do scenes with her he was
watching everything that was going on
between and around them but found
himself utterly shocked when watching
the movie back there were these little
movements facial expressions and
subtleties in her acting that he never
picked up on during their scenes
together only realizing it all after
watching it back now what are some of
your favorite Scarlett Johansson films
alright that UFO scene was one of the
most chaotic sequences they shot
throughout the entire film that
had to be shot in different pieces over
different amounts of time and tactic and
it was hectic one minute they'd be
working on a specific shot for it and
then Wes would be like hey actually can
you run over and shoot this instead they
also had a difficult time trying to
direct the kids when it came to looking
up at the UFO Now look up up what's that
what's that they had to be pretty
inventive to get them to look up in a
way like they were actually seeing
something impressive and look up look up
whoa what's up there is that Mickey
Mouse they also had a chaotic day with
all of the machinery and explosions they
had to organize and there's this massive
piece of equipment that our dog grips on
is like trying not to run people over
with and everyone had to make sure they
were right on their Mark or else you
have to make sure you stay right on your
mark so you don't get decapitated by a
crane it's giving chaos
and speaking of chaos let's talk about
Jeff Goldblum on stilts in an alien
costume now Jeff Goldblum is already a
pretty tall guy Jeff Odom's already like
a thousand feet tall and then he's on
stilt so he's then 2 000 feet tall so
when you think it couldn't get any worse
than being on stilts in a constricting
alien costume so he couldn't see
anything
yeah totally blind obviously he
practiced walking on stilts before
getting into the costume but I can only
imagine how scary it would be walking
like that when you can't see every time
he finished a short walk we would all
stand up and Applause because we just
couldn't believe what he was doing okay
so remember how I was talking about
Rupert Friend and Maya Hawks improvised
dance scene yeah Rupert was super scared
to do that in front of everybody
specifically the Cowboys it was one of
those you know especially when I found
out the rest of the Cowboys are all
professional musicians he admires all of
them as musicians and couldn't fathom
the thought of singing and dancing in
front of guys who could eat up his
performance for breakfast a lot of
people in this cast that wouldn't have
been daunted by that I wasn't one of
them so yeah not only did Rupert learn
the lasso he also had to learn lap steel
guitar dude was literally shaking in his
boots performing in front of Maya who's
also a professional musician and an
entire cast of seasoned artists who do
this in their sleep I couldn't give
Rupert higher higher marks it's clear
that the cast of asteroid City formed
strong friendships and a genuine Bond
throughout the filming process because I
work in trenches battlefields and combat
zones their shared experiences on and
offset contributed to a positive and
collaborative atmosphere and of course
the opportunity to work with Wes
Anderson add in an extra layer of
excitement to the project what were you
most surprised to find out about the set